jedes Bundesland hat seine Spezialitäten
egal ob es Thüringer Rostbratwurst
Hamburger Franzbrötchen oder Berliner
Currywurst ist doch die Frage die wir
uns heute stellen ist welche Spezialität
ist die beste in Deutschland deshalb
habe ich also chatgpt nach vier
Gerichten pro Bundesland gefragt und
euch auf Instagram abstimmen lassen so
hatte ich dann 16 Gerichte die
stellvertretend jeweils für ein
Bundesland stehen diese werden wir
allesam testen und in eine tierlist
einordnen S ist das beste F ist das
schlechteste ihr kennt die bestimmt aus
dem Internet die große Inspiration für
dieses Video das ist natürlich ganz klar
ist wie so oft Joshua Wiseman ich bin
ein riesen Fan er hat das mit den
amerikanischen Bundesstaaten gemacht
verlinke ich euch auch unten und jetzt
viel Spaß mit dem Video als erstes haben
wir für badenwürtemberg Maultaschen mit
schwäbischenem Kartoffelsalat die
Maultaschen sind gefüllt mit Hackfleisch
Spinat Gewürzen und Zwiebeln oben drauf
ein paar Röstzwiebeln und natürlich ein
schwäbischer Kartoffelsalat dazu
Kandidat Nummer ein probieren wir ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen das ist schon
heißer Favorit für mich weil Leute
lieben nicht ohne grundmaultaschen ich
glaube ich kann mich nicht erinnern dass
ich das jemals gegessen habe nein nein
Brier
BR ist halber Schwabe deshalb die Welt
bricht zusammen probieren
wir boah das hängt die Latte auf jeden
Fall hoch boah ist das gewürzig aber es
ist auch das erste was wir jetzt essen
aber es hat halt auch alles ne finde das
wirklich herausragend ist ist diese
Würzigkeit dieser Maultasche ich finde
die sieht nämlich total unspektakulär
aus ja aber das ist so geschmackvoll das
wird auf jeden Fall schwer ready ein
Z was hast du B a BR Bry muss als
Schwabe auf jeden Fall essen es ist auch
einfach das beste Essen ich war auch
versucht ein ess zu geben aber ich
wollte nicht direkt zum Anfang eins
geben weil das ist krank geil dann
bwürtenberg ne auf a a ist schon fucking
strong zum Anfang true der bayerische
Klassiker Laugenbrezel mit Weißwurst und
süßem Senf die Weißwurst ganz wichtig
nicht gekocht sondern langsam erwärmt
muss man gegessen haben nicht nur beim
Oktoberfest Zeit für Bavaria Leute gönnt
euch ein bisschen Brezel budet hat nicht
gereicht dass jeder hat auch hier
streiten sich die Geister wie istst man
jetzt eine Weißwurst ich glaub jeder hat
seine eigene Technik bisschen Weißwurst
süßer
sen also das ist jetzt bisschen unfair
weil wir haben hier im Büro eine Zeit
lang immer Weißwurst Frühstück gemacht
und das hat so auch so ein nostalgischen
Wert geil soll man sagen sehr einfaches
auch was ein was fehlt ist ein Bier
eigentlich sehr sehr schwer
einzuschätzen aber was ich da eine Note
geben soll nach den ersten zwei Spots
den in Deutschland hat nur geiles Essen
das erinnert sich noch es wird noch wild
ein Z D b b a also ich habe auch a
überlegt und dann ist mir das wirklich
aufgefallen das ist ein geiles eine
geile Tradition es macht Spaß das ist
was Eigenes aber rein geschmacklich
hatast es nicht nicht zum a geschafft
finde ich erste B jetzt alles ist jetzt
zum ersten Mal
Pass echte Berliner Currywurst frisch
gekocht von uns natürlich keine normale
Bratwurst sondern eine Berliner
Currywurst Bratwurst dazu eine tomatige
Currysoße eine Schrippe und und gib ih
wollen wir mal ne seid gut drauf macht
so viel
Richtigung die Geiern
alle kann auch Currywurst jeder Tages
und Nachtzeit Essen das wir wirklich
schwer seid ihr bereit SS go Currywurst
Alter was was willst du sagen mein
stellt euch mal vor in Berlin so eine
echte Currywurst die du dir so
unfreundlich so vors Gesicht geklatscht
wird und du denkst ein so sorry dass ich
lebe und dann istst du ein bisschen
davon bist einfach im Himmel ich glaub
gerade in Berlin kannst du bestimmt bei
100 verschiedenen Läden currybus Essen
dadurch auch zurecht hier auf der S aber
findet ihr die so way more better den
Maultasche mhm
ja frische sprewaldgurken wir müssen
nicht weit wir müssen von Berlin nach
Brandenburg und einfach nur das Fass
öffnen darin schwimmen sie nämlich mit
Zwiebeln mit Dill eingelegt einfach ein
deutscher Klassiker ich glaube man liebt
sie oder man hast sie bin sehr gespannt
ich glaube das wird kontrovers darf ich
dir hier so frech eine Gurke anbieten
darfst du sehr sehr gerne ja ich will
nicht zu viel wegnehmen was sagt ihr zu
so gewürzkuren übelst geil übelst geil
ich habe es lange Zeit nur auf Burger
[Musik]
gemacht sehr süß sehr süß so süß dass
sie schon eher so ein Snack sind die
gewürzabstimmung ist das was sie
wirklich besonders macht find ich das
stimmt wenn man so eine Gewürzgurke
sieht dann dann denkt man jede schmeckt
gleich ihr denkt jetzt so die schmeckt
gleich aber die schmeckt ganz anders als
andere g tut das war jetzt aber auch
sehr positiv alles was wir gesagt haben
für Gurken vergleichen halt Currywurst
mit Gurken so das ist 3 2 1 du hast a
gegeben das zwei beste es ist für eine
saure Gurke sehr geil aber es ist eine
saure Gurke aber es ist eine saure Gurke
ich bin gespannt ob noch ein F ein E und
ein D kommen ich kannst mir aber gut
vorstellen bei dem was noch kommt
nächste Speise hat keiner von uns jemals
gegessen Bremer Kluten seit 1909 gibt es
die so schon die werden auf jeden Fall
richtig sein ich bin sehr gespannt ich
bin aber auch froh dass mal was Süßes
für zwischendurch finde das sieht aus
wür man jetzt in so ein Zuckerwürfel
beißen irgendwie so ein bisschen gen
probieren
wir verminz mal kurz
Zahnpasta ist das flüssig gefüllt Alter
das schmilzt ja so Weg am Ende wird's
geiler es füllt wirklich deinen Mund mit
frische oder halt mit Zahnpasta wie man
möchte und es hat eine
Daseinsberechtigung das wird verdammt
spannend 3 2 1 zweimal e ich habe D
gegeben ich hab f
jung weil ich habe jetzt gerade zwar
gesagt dass ganz lecker ist ne aber beim
dritten war es echt eklig also ich habe
mein Körper hat sich schon so bisschen
gewehrt wenn mir jemand würde ich nein
sagen nein
danke ist ein Klass e scheißt auf jeden
Fall rein tut mir sehr leid für Bremen
aber ihr hab einen besonderen Geschmack
als nächstes gibt es Franzbrötchen aus
Hamburg der Teig gewordene Traum von der
Elbe wer ist
franzle Franzbrötchen sind eine
Spezialität aus H und verdanken ihren
Namen vermutlich einem historischen
Bezug zu
Frankreich französische Soldaten oder
einwander könnten das ursprüngliche
kossant eingeführt haben und die
Hamburger Bäcker passten es an indem sie
es mit Zimt und Zucker
füllten deswegen
Croissant es ist wirklich bildhübsch
also ein Franzbrötchen ist was Tolles
unten dieser karamellisierte Zimtzucker
kennt ihr das wenn wenn man sagt so Tage
sind so Farben oder Zahlen sind
Farben
ich glaub ich glaub die sprwaldgurke hat
nicht gut getan
tikt die Zahl se ist grün für ein oder
dre ist gelb worauf willst du hinaus er
trau Dich wir verurteilen dich nicht
welche Farbe hat für dich das
Franzbrötchen weil für mich ist das so
ein beige so leicht bräunlich gehen wir
wollen das wissen die Zuschauer wollen
das auch Wissen der Bogen muss jetzt zu
Ende gespannt werden welche Farbe sag es
jetzt das keine Farbe ich find das
riecht nach Umarmung
das do wundersön schön
ja krass mm kurz und schmerzlos Männer 3
1 time
limitam a SSA wow ohne Witz ich habe
gerade kurz drüber nachgedacht es ist
das beste Süßgebäck aus Deutschland
kriegt fettes
die Stadtstaaten regieren die
Stadtstaaten da ganz oben mit dabeiit
geht mit Hessen und richen mit Kraut wir
haben eine Art Kassler oben drauf dann
Sauerkraut was aus Weißkraut gewonnen
wird das fermentiert wird dazu eben das
Kassler und für mich persönlich sehr
nostalgisch weil ich bin an der Grenze
zwischen Hessen und Bayern groß geworden
und habe deshalb beides kennengelernt
und das hier habe ich früher ganz oft
gegessen fin das ist sehr sehr deutsch
super Deutsch
ja das ist so nostalgisch für mich lass
mich nicht lügen Alter ich habe das
bestimmt 10 Jahre nicht gegessen ich
find auch
geil so ein besonderen Geschmack den man
halt nicht kennt wenn man es nicht
gegessen hat dann würde man das nicht
verstehen das passt einfach Gil zusammen
das FCH ist no joke so zart wie so ein
Filet wie so ein
rinderfil ein C B ja BBC es ist wirklich
für mich persönlich hätte fast noch
höher gegeben aber objektiv finde ich
das ein B Bayern und Hessen da
erschaffenbur B btier einfach nur kein a
kein s aber auch nichts schlechteres
hoch oben im Norden liegt mcklenburg
vorpom und für mcpom gibt es ein
Fischbrötchen das hat meisten Stimmen
bekommen und wir probieren es jetzt wie
geht's euch mit dem was vor uns auf dem
Teller ist eigentlich liebe ich das Aug
zu und durch wir tun es für
mcpom man hätte sich denken können aber
es schmeckt weniger schlimm als man
denken würde von der Gurke tut dem
Sachen der ganzen Sache richtig gut
finde ich aber mir geht's auch ein
bisschen wie dir ich finde die Zwiebel
sehr wichtig das ist full Fisch ja da
muss man richtig Bock drauf haben eecec
ich hoffe es wird besser weitergehen D
komm okay kom ist ja ein Mittelwert aus
unseren Meinungen dann lassen wir es be
D wir bleiben im Norden und somit in
Niedersachsen wir haben hier Grünkohl
mit Pinkel klingt ein bisschen schlimm
ich habe es glaube ich noch nie gegessen
glaube aber dass es fast jeder andere
Mensch schon mal gegessen hat weil es
ist sehr populär aber ich bin nicht
sicher was mich erwartet ich probiere
erstmal Grünkohl weil Pinkel okay Alter
wie kann etwas was Grünkohl heißt so
lecker schmecken es ist nicht nur
Grünkohl ne das ist ein grünkohlintopf
man merkt richtig das ist so eine
richtig so eine dichte deutsche Wurst ja
war echt die ist wirklich so richtig
kompakt
Attacke feiner gewürzt als gedacht ich
dachte es sei saltigiger und kräftiger
Deutschland ist wirklich so fucking
stupide wir essen die ganze Zeit Wurst
mit Soße später kommt Wurst ohne alles
ich bin echt überrascht über die Note
die ich jetzt gebe Eric what the [__]
das einzige was diesem Gericht im Weg
steht die Welt zu erobern ist die Optik
treffen wir uns beim A oder treffen uns
beim A und auch völlig zurecht wow top
vi jetzt gerade haben wir ih einen
echten Weihnachtsmarkt Klassiker ein
Reibekuchen straight aouer NRW mit
Apfelkompott probieren wir das gute
Stück e ohne witch der Crunch macht
übelst Spaß und frittierte Kartoffel
sind jetzt die reinenländer nicht die
ersten die herausgefunden haben dass das
geil ist wir müssen abstimmen guter
Reibekuchen Mama mir D Z ein SSA ich
find Currywurst und franzbrchen krasser
ja ich finde es nicht krasser ich find
für mich das ist 100% esstier aber
Mittelwert ist ja auch S das heißt ein
von drei sesstier Sachen wir werden
natürlich ein Gesamtgewinner küren am
Ende von diesem Video weshalb sich auf
jeden Fall lohnt dran zu bleiben und
dann wird das hier mal ordentlich
ausdiskutiert aber jetzt würde ich
erstmal sagen weiter geht's zum nächsten
Bundesland die erste Dampfnudel die ich
je gemacht habe sieht glaube ich ganz
gut aus ich hoffe die Leute aus reinand
F s nicht sauer auf mich wir probieren
das Ding
jetzt
m on point noch nie gegessen ne das
ernst krank diger Alter ich wusste nicht
dass es so lecker ist man braucht aber
viel Soße Vanillesoße auch einfach krass
SS hast du auch S gegeben s nein ich
habe a alter Schwede SSA ohne Witz ich
habe die ganze Zeit so vom ersten Moment
habe ich gedacht okay das ist s und dann
ich wollte das aber gar nicht aber es
ist einfach auch überlegt so ist das
jetzt eine S ist s es ist leider ein S
es ist ein S ja fünf sind noch übrig und
die lassen wir uns noch schmecken
straight auder Dresden dresner Stollen
für mich ein absoluter
Weihnachtsklassiker gibt es immer bei
uns mit Rosinen drin ich glaub Mandeln
sind auch dabei und der fühlt sich schon
zuckrig und buttrig an mir fällt gerade
auf dass ich schon krasser emann bin
weil so manche Sachen davon erinnern
mich einfach so krass an so Kindheit und
an zu Hause und so es ist für mich aber
etwas stark seonales für mich ist das
Weihnachten komm wenn du mir im Sommer
damit kommst habe ich ja gar keine Lust
drauf aber geschmacklich ist das schon
echt gut aber denkst du da drüben ne
Essen die das so das ganze ja
dr das ist echt ein schwieriges Ranking
meiner Meinung der ist schwer
einzuordnen ne super schwer super schwer
BB D D du hast es was hast du für eine
persönliche Hasskampagne gegen dresner
Stollen ich fin es ist ein schlechter
Kuchen also ich finde das ist für mich
so gut wie weißwürstel so gut wie
kassper deswegen gehen wir auf B
Kompromiss ist ja Meinungspluralismus
rein ins B Sachsen luftanhalt der ist
ein Harzer Käse los geht's da müssen wir
durch ein großer deutscher Poet hat mal
gesagt wabilla wabilla du siehst aus wie
mein kleiner Finger nach 5 Stunden baden
und ich glaube er meinte Harzer Käse ich
habe schon mal gegessen ich dachte mir
so boah nice viel Protein und so dachte
auch bis zu dem Zeitpunkt wo ich das
gegessen habe so Käse kann nur schmecken
für Magus machen wir das für Magus schon
mal
einstellen wow welches Land ist das
saagen Anhalt warum machen die das wir
sind uns einig also du hast ja gesagt du
fandst es nicht so schlimm wie gedacht
aber es war trotzdem schlecht genug für
ein F
sofort ein fand das wirklich ab dem
Moment wo ich reingewisen hab eklig ja
tut mir leid sag Anhalt das war absolut
scheiße der eigentliches daar im
Saarland ist diese Wurst hier die lona
bzw wie man im Saarland sagen würde der
Leona wir haben ja eine Leona Pfanne
gemacht mit dem Spiegelei paar
Kartoffeln und die hier repräsentiert
das salan lassen wir uns schmecken
hoffentlich es sieht echt nicht verkehrt
aus ne sieht super lecker aus
g ich find geil dass wir Bratkartoffeln
mit auf der Liste haben dadurch m das
ist sehr geil aber sind keine
bradkartoffel ist eine Leon Pfanne die
Leon Pfanne finde ich auch geil ja
übelst ja rein in die Masse es gibst du
sa Bro aber so gut wie currywurf so gut
wie Franzbrötchen so gut wie diese
dampfnudelade brud das mache ich mir
Sonntags Mittags wenn ich so
aufgestanden bin mit wirklich mit den
Resten und da dann dann esse ich das so
mit so viel Herz
alter das ist krass das kann echt so ein
Ausreißer vielleicht sein bei mir dann
lass auf B machen gehen wir auf B b b
gutter okay das ist ja nicht schlecht
top Holsteiner Schnitzel aus Schleswig
Holstein hat wenig mit dem Schnitzel zu
tun dass ich kenne und dass ich mag wir
haben Räucherlachs wir haben sadellen
wir haben Karpern das sind schon mal
drei Dinge die die allermeisten Menschen
glaube ich nicht mögen wir lassen uns
trotzdem darauf ein und testen das ganze
ich habe heute mindestens vier oder fünf
Sachen das erste Mal sogar gehört nicht
dass ich die noch nie gegessen SN sogar
gehört ja aufstäßwig Holstein ausstäwig
Holstein al das ist halt ein Schnitzel
wo der umami Regler wirklich mal ganz
weit aufgedreht wurde also du hast
wirklich so eine Vollmundigkeit für mich
ist es auch ein bisschen zu viel man
weiß nicht was man schmecken soll
bisschen zu viel was abgeht CEE ich
hatte wir haben immer so ein einer
springt immer so einer fällt so ein
bisschen aus der Reihe waren noch nicht
einmal alle einig nee noch nie für mich
ist das eigentlich das Problem weil
eigentlich ist jedes einzelbandteil
geiler ist die Summe des ganzen das ist
sehr schön gesagt ist eine kleine
Geschmacksverirrung zum Abschluss bzw
noch nicht ganz zum Abschluss denn ein
Bundesland haben wir noch eine Thüringer
Rostbratwurst im Brötchen Deutschland in
mitten von zwei Brothälften wir fallen
langsam keine neuen Überleitung mehr ein
dafür dass wir das jetzt essen deshalb
ja wir essen das jetzt große
Finale ich glaube wir sind nervlich
körperlich und geschmacklich am Ende
aber das hier geht eigentlich immer ja
das ist einfach eine stadionr brabecher
und Bier ich bra ein Bier und ich Brau
tribü und ich will auch jemanden jetzt
beleidigen finde das unglaublich geil
und das am Ende von fucking 16 Gerichten
fucking 15 Gerichte hier vorgegessen es
muss auch dieses rudige bröchen sein Bo
ist geil ver piickte schei Thüringen 1 Z
3 diger das ist wirklich krank wenn
etwas so gut schmeckt nachdem man den
ganzen Tag gegessen hat dann ist das
einfach
GA das ist einfach ein Gericht für jeden
Tag das repräsentiert Deutschland das
ist einfach das ist einfach perfekt aber
nur weil es dreimal s bekommen hat heißt
noch nicht automatisch dass das beste
unter den SARS ist wir haben jetzt auf
Platz s die Berliner Currywurst das
Hamburger Franzbrötchen Reibekuchen aus
NRW Dampfnudel aus rheinlandpalz und
Thüringer Rostbratwurst unter den fünf
sagt jetzt noch mal jeder seinen
Favoriten Currywurst türingen türingen
das Ding ist Currywurst will ich nicht
jeden Tag Essen die Süßspeisen sind
unfassbar geil aber ich bin einfach
nicht so sehr süßer Typ dass ich als
bestes Gericht aus Deutschland eine
Süßspeise werden kann deshalb
Franzbrötchen Dampf sind raus ich glaube
dann mus wenn wenn ihr jetzt Thüringen
sagt dann macht das aber für mich ist es
eine Niederlage dann muss du sie
akzeptieren ja werde ich dann auch
vielleicht seid ihr ja genau wie Eric
und denkt euch gerade warum haben diese
blöden [__] eine scheiß Bratwurst zum
besten Gericht Deutschlands gewählt aber
es ist irgendwie schon fast
philosophisch nachdem wir den ganzen Tag
nur deuts Gerichte gegessen haben wer
kann das schon sagen dass er das gemacht
hat was wir heute gemacht
haben und was vielleicht auch
wunderschön ist in beiden Gerichten
spelt eine Wurst die größte Rolle
welcome to Germany ich hoffe das Video
hat Euch gefallen es war jetzt wirklich
viel also ich bin mir ganz sicher da
sind viele draußen die sich denken ja
das habt ihr falsch gemacht das habt ihr
falsch gemacht das habt ihr falsch
gemacht warum habt ihr das nicht
genommen es ist fast unmöglich das
perfekt abzubilden aber es hat auf jeden
Fall sehr viel Spaß gemacht wir haben
einiges über Deutschland und die
Kulinarik gelernt und einen Gewinner
gefunden und ich bin gespannt was ihr
dazu sagt wir sehen uns beim nächsten
Mal wieder macht's gut ciao ciao